CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend is with us she was
homeland security and counterterrorism
advisor for president george w bush ran
here we are yet again another mass
shooting and now that the shooter is
killed walk us through what authorities
are doing to try to identify who he was
and what his motive could have been so
the first thing they'll do we know that
they're going through the crime scene
right that bar that entire bar is a
crime scene they're also trying to keep
the witnesses the victims who are
outside sort of assembled you'll get the
ones who need medical attention first
but they all have to be interviewed the
crime scene has to be gone through
they're tracing the gun right now right
is that a weapon that was legally or
illegally obtained and how did he obtain
it they'll take the fingerprints of the
dead gunmen to try and identify him that
way they'll look for what was on his
body we call pocket litter did he was he
carrying anything that would identify
him or would give them a clue as to the
motive all of that is what's going on
right now to try and make sense of this
sort of awful tragedy and now a friend
in a two-week period a synagogue a yoga
studio a bar that the sheriff said is
really a good place is not a rowdy
location do we need to rethink these
soft targets how do you protect soft
targets and do we need to rethink that
well Gail just as you list them you you
know it becomes obvious it's almost
impossible to protect every soft target
and in fairness to the bard the country
bar he in this case they had a security
guard outside now he wasn't armed right
but you know we go through active
shooter drills the synagogue had been
through an active shooter drill very you
know like a week or two before the event
we you know the Department of Homeland
Security does what they can to prepare
people for this sort of a eventualities
but look we ought to be honest there's a
larger issue about guns in this country
that we're going to have to turn our
attention to or we're gonna continue to
do this every week and they're saying
this was not an assault rifle it was a
handgun right but what we don't know is
what kind of a handgun was it did it
have a semi-automatic capability we
don't know enough about it yet all right
Fran more questions to come thanks so
much for being with us